this is not going to be easy my gosh
i i i'll start with now we'll get again
the chiefs and buccaneers already have a
spot
nfl super league i will start with the
green bay packers
right you started with oh thy great one
because you know he'll be allowed in any
league
right but it's not just who they
currently have this is big picture small
picture
cache right current ability the the the
eight elite teams but not just a
snapshot of today
there's got to be some history in it and
the packers packers have both right now
yeah they do they do
they're good right now they got history
and they got you know
oh that great one and oh aaron rodgers
so that makes sense no doubt about it
i'm with you there
um all right well i'm going with the
ravens next the ravens
to me just from a pure roster standpoint
deserve to be in the league i mean of
course what they've done the last two
years
lamar jackson everything like that one
of the better defenses in football
i mean they're they're the cream of the
crop as far as the nfl is concerned and
they have a quarterback that's in their
prime and a lot of other good players
that are in prime so to me
that was an easy one as far as just like
base level
safe pick ravens in the super league
wow i i i i was saying wow you weren't
sure
i i thought you were going to go 49ers
right out of the gates
questionable six six super bowl
championships nothing questionable about
that they have six or five they got five
stupiders and the patriots have
six i'll go steelers then steelers have
six steelers always relevant always
contending
always important to the league you can't
have a super league without
the super steelers pittsburgh steelers
my second pick this one's going very
well for me so far
yeah okay i know yeah you got two teams
that are like you know
hanging on by a thread good job i mean
yes
you're i'm going more of like i think
the
talent on the field aspect right now
you're going more than nostalgia
and like packers were 13 and three i
know 11-0 right what are you talking
about i know okay well either way you
don't even think the steelers are any
damn good we'll see all right
all right i'm gonna go with the bills
then i am going with the bills next i'm
going with the bills cause
again one i think they're a good playoff
they're a playoff football team two
years in a row
and they got one of the five best
players in the sport at quarterback with
josh allen he's a superstar
so yeah from that aspect i am gonna take
the bills there
um you know there's just too many
positives about them even though they
might not have the history the big name
the big market
they're too damn good right now for them
not to be in the super league
this one is very very difficult oh where
are you going that i seriously
considered
seriously considered in this spot was
the dallas cowboys but you know what 25
years
without making it to a conference
championship game
that there's a price to be paid there
remember they got flexed out of a sunday
night game last year they're not getting
the super league you better not as
co-commissioner you better not put them
in our league no
sorry america's team yeah well america's
different right now all right so sorry
this one's a coin flip this one's a coin
flip for me between the seahawks and the
saints i'll take the saints
okay you're gonna go with the saints all
right i mean they were both on my list
there too
i i get it i mean uh the saints
they've been relevant for too long and
yeah the roster is still damn good and
it's sean payton i mean i get that
i get that i think there's two better
options out there right now
right like my last pick i'm stuck with
the rams and the saints
i mean not the rams and the saints the
rams and the browns
all right there's a lot of big time
stars on both of these rosters of course
you got the la thing right
with some star power and stafford and
mcvay and aaron donald and jalen ramsey
but the browns do have the history thing
and are kind of like
got some new stars recent history but
yeah it's recent history
it's old old history it's ancient
history in really really recent history
the rest in between is kind of really
average
i'm going to go with the browns right
now i am i'm going with the browns the
browns ate the browns
yep with those offensive linemen and the
quarterback and the receiver they got
miles garrett and jaedevian clowney the
browns ain't the browns no more
super league baby
uh wow um
you went to traditional power c north
yeah three teams from the afc north look
at that
ravens steelers and browns all in the
super league packers bills saints the
others and the chiefs bucks get the
get the buy they get the automatic entry
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports